depuis quinze ans je travaille sur ce
qu'apporte les neurosciences au
management et à l'information et plus
spécifiquement pour regarder les
caractéristiques et évaluer les
dirigeants ce qui m'amène à vous
proposer trois critères qui avec
l'expérience et de benchmark comme on
dit parès me paraissent discriminant
pour le dirigeant premier critère
il faut savoir oublier tout ce qu'on
sait oubliez tous ces schémas de pensée
si le dirigeant veut être à l'essentiel
de ce qu'est sa fonction regarder le
futur et capter tout ce qui va bouger
dans son environnement
les métiers les nouvelles technologies
les clients les concurrents les cadres
légaux
ceci n'est pas très facile parce que
cela sollicite des réseaux neuronaux qui
sont assez compliquées à mobiliser c'est
à dire les réseaux de l'inhibition dans
ce test de ce troupe bien connu il vous
est demandé de d'appuyer sur un bouton
quand vous voyez un mot qui apparaît
d'une couleur de peau lisse rouges ou
vertes printemps donc le mode téléphone
appareil il est en bleu je clique pas le
mot bicyclette apparaît en rouge flics
ça se complique un petit peu quand le
mot qui apparaît désigne une couleur
cela il ya conflit parce que
intuitivement et presque
de façon irrépressible j'ai envie de
dire non il ya le mot vert donc c'est
pas rouge
sauf que comme le mot vert était écrit
en police rouge
il fallait que je clique ceci illustre
assez bien la difficulté que nous avons
à mobiliser des réseaux de l'émission
qui nous empêche en quelque sorte de
recourir à ce que serait une la
tentation de répondre immédiatement de
façon presque irrépressible à partir de
ce que l'on sait donc je connais bien
les mots de couleur ou de ce que l'on
s'aime et schémas de pensée les
décisions que j'ai pu prétendre passer
donc pour le décideur c'est la même
chose c'est difficile d'écarter
d'oublier ce qu'il ce qui a été le fruit
de son expérience et encore plus lorsque
se dispersant cette expérience et celle
de l' expertise
prenant l'exemple on a regardé où le on
a équipé les deux médecins patron de
néphrologie 53 ans il en a vu des
clichés de tumeurs du rein et son jeune
chef de clinique 27 ans et donc on a
regardé où sont le regard de chacun se
portait immédiatement quand on
présentait un cliché le patron avec
toute son expérience
immédiatement ils allaient dans telle
zone du rhin il identifiait les tumeurs
ils disaient qu'ils chez suivant le
jeune chef de clinique lui il avait fait
un balayage visuel du rein du cliché il
avait vu bien sûr le point relevé par
son patron le problème pour lui
pour la suite c'est qu'il avait vu aussi
en bas petites zones qui pourraient être
prédictive de là les difficultés dans le
monde franco-français de l'hospital aux
universitaires commençait pour lui
fallait-il isa monsieur ya peut-être ça
également puisque le chef était déjà en
train de parler du duce suivant
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que on a
grande difficulté à freiner résister aux
tentations de lire ce que l'on voit a
fortiori si c'est sur ce qui se passe
pour le futur à partir de nos lunettes
de nos regards de nos schémas de pensée
issus de notre soleil expérience
deuxième critère qui paraît
discriminante pour le malade le
dirigeant c'est d'être capable de
développer au maximum
l'agilité et la l'autonomie le degré
d'autonomie de ses collaborateurs à
travers tous les process de formation
qui sont mises en oeuvre et ceux ci fait
référence à la manière dont le cerveau
apprend alors comment le cerveau apprend
quand on fait des petits exercices pour
peu qu'ils soient bien calibrée on
trouve facilement la réponse pays se
passe immédiatement dans le cerveau
l'activation du des réseaux
dopaminergiques de la récompense de la
réussite
j'ai réussi je suis heureux j'ai même
envie de à nouveau essayer c'est donc un
facteur qui augmente la confiance en soi
et la motivation est donc envie d
essayer et c'est ainsi par des petits
bouts d'exercice que je vais peut-être à
prendre plus facilement des
connaissances alors il en découle de
conséquence importante la première c'est
la manière dont doit être conçu un
dispositif de formation
découpé en petits morceaux si possible
dans des dimensions le plus ludique
possible pour que ce réseau
dopaminergiques de l'est de la réussite
me fasse être heureux de réussir
augmenter ma confiance en soi me motiver
et faire en sorte que le cerveau
alimentent bien active bien le système
dopaminergique
il en découle une deuxième conséquence
qui est un peu plus difficile à
appréhender c'est le fait que pour bien
acquérir une connaissance a priori et
donc la réutiliser dans le futur il vaut
mieux l'avoir apprise dans des
conditions d'utilisation différentes
je m'explique on est chacun ici tous
instituteur dans une classe ce2 élèves
de 8 ans et on a à faire la leçon ce
système fluvial
donc on va expliquer ici on avec saurait
dire vous voyez les enfants système
pluvial c'est un gros fleuve le rhône
qui se jette dans la méditerranée qui
est alimenté par des rivières des petits
affluents extérieur et puis parce qu'on
est plutôt sympa et condat capacité à
s'écarter un petit peu des règles de
l'éducation nationale et ds que
prescrivent dans les programmes les
inspecteurs on va rajouter une autre
image
après l'image du simple via l'image du
système sanguin
on va dire oui à des broutards terre des
grosses veines jamais vous et moi on
aura prononcé le mot abscons
arborescence relations d'ordre aux huit
ans même si eux on sait que dès l'âge de
6 ans l'enfant est capable d'aller au
niveau conceptuel
ce qui fait retourner un peu ça tombe
bien j'ai mais peu importe pour lui et
si nous avons un peu l'audace disruptive
initiative de dire aux enfants
ça vous fait penser à quoi ces deux
images mais très vite vous allez voir un
enfant qui va les lourds dire mais
monsieur c c'est comme un gros arbre un
gros tronc il ya des grosses branches
éléments il en train d'utiliser le
concept abord s en soit si on dort death
or que je lui ai prononcés ceci donc un
nouveau contexte d'utilisation il
utilise ce qu'il vient d'apprendre à
traire les deux premières images ya un
troisième qui va lever la main et qui va
dire mais c'est comme dans la maison de
campagne des grands parents nous avec
tous les petits cousins on est en bas
pia rôle et riza yeux et puis
c'est la même chose que votre il ya là
un quatrième un cinquième qui va dire
moi un jour j'ai demandé à mon papa ou
que tu fais dans l'entreprise tu as des
chefs tadeusz est à qui on va mal et
montrer un tableau avec eux il sait pas
comment ils appellent un ordi
organigramme quoi et donc voilà les
enfants qui par eux mêmes on était
capable d'utiliser le concept que je
leur ai enseigné
ça s'appelle la didactique du transfert
80% des dispositifs de formation dans
les entreprises quelles dépenses ne sont
pas inclus pas cette notion de
l'identique du transfert donc ne
développe pas le niveau d'autonomie des
collaborateurs et cette agilité à
utiliser ce qu'ils ont appris dans de
nouveaux contextes d'utilisation
troisième critère ça c'est celui qui va
un peu plus secoué les neurones nombre
d'entre nous sommes de l'entreprise
c'est que le dirigeant doit apprendre la
lenteur pour bien décider on a tous
appris que très bon décideurs c'est
celui qui décide vivent même dans les
situations complexes et bien c'est
complètement faux voilà gobet qu'un au
säntis connu il a pris des grands
maîtres d'échecs
il les a mis dans un irm et il a regardé
comment qu'est-ce qui s'activait comme
dans cortex préfrontal
lorsque le joueur d'échecs réfléchissait
dans les positions très complexe à ce
que devait être le coup qui devait
décider de jouer et donc on a vu 30 35
minutes quarante minutes et on a vu des
caisses qui sept s'étaient activés
on les a soumis une deuxième condition
le redis maintenant aurait pu que cinq
minutes pour décider et on s'est aperçu
que c'était d'autres raisons dans le
cortex préfrontal qui fonctionnait et le
résultat d'ailleurs dans les deux cas
c'est que dans le premier cas il y avait
beaucoup plus de parties gagnantes avec
la décision prise avec toute la lenteur
danalyse d'intégration des données
complexes versus le cas où le coup était
beaucoup plus perdants parce que le
temps n'avait pas été laissé pour
intégrer toutes les données
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ça
illustre une courbe en u inversé
lorsque je suis pressé par le temps pour
décider
le système fabrique de plus en plus le
stress a comme caractéristique de faire
fabriquer de plus en plus de dopamine
n'aurait de la ligne mais si je dépasse
le haut de la courbe en u
là je prends le risque de tomber à un
niveau de saturation or qu'est ce qui se
passe quand ceux ci arrivent à la
synapse pour la connexion pour aller
faire ce que doit faire c'est à dire
sortait une décision mais lorsque à
saturation
il ya des connexions le corps tu le
système exécutif dit non c'est trop
compliqué pour moi j'abandonne en fait
c'est plus perverse à il n'abandonne pas
du tout il bascule dans un système
automatique où il va chercher des choses
qu'il a plus connu dans le passé et donc
il prend la mauvaise décision
ou en tout cas il altère sensiblement la
qualité de la décision par rapport à
toutes les données qui ne veut plus
intégrées parce que c'est trop con
billets pour lui parce qu'on l'a trop
pressés dans le temps donc ça veut bien
dire que
pour le décideur être capable de prendre
le temps plus il ya des données
complexes est un élément essentiel ce
qui va complètement à l'encontre des
idées qu'on peut avoir des idées reçues
qu'on peut avoir dans ce domaine soit
est terminée donc pour en quelque sorte
faire une programmation non pas parce
que j'étais un bilan de passer
simplement pour dire que aux chefs
d'entreprise
j'ai envie de leur dire occupez vous de
ce qui est l'essentiel pour vous et
n'essayez pas de faire tout ce que des
gens beaucoup plus compétents que ou peu
veut faire au sein de votre comex vous
votre job c'est le futur captée dans
votre radar tout ce qui est en train de
bouger de changer ce qui peut vous
éviter le syndrome de nokia
comment le premier numéro un mondial de
télécoms a pu rater l'épisode 2 du
tactile donc occupez-vous de futures
prenez votre temps pour décider
veillez à ce que la ressource le capital
ressources essentielles de votre
entreprise
reste à gilles mobile après le mieux
possible
et puis faites en sorte que l'aide le
changement la transformation de vienne
la vertu première de votre entreprise et
pour ça hâtez-vous lentement les anciens
disaient festina lente et je vous
remercie